we have been shooting in this theater in
largo theater for quite a while now
and it's been really nice for us and i
want to bring this up because you are no
stranger to the largo theater you're a
regular here at this theater and that's
one of the reasons i kind of advocated
if you guys were comfortable with it of
getting tested and coming here because
this is like
i mean this has been a really important
place to me for many many years even at
its old location but
our dear friend mark flanagan who owns
the place there he is
native son of uh belfast uh get quave to
the crowd flanny
that's uh yeah he he runs flanagan or
we call him flanny runs uh runs the
theater here and does a lovely job
doesn't shut up yeah uh we've had a big
problem with that
they say if you don't if you want
something kept secret don't don't tell
flanny because it's telegraph
telephone tell a flanny
[Laughter]
whatever you tell him will be dispersed
among a large network
pretty fast yeah no i'd love to but you
brought this up but it really is like
there's an irish mafia because a lot of
theaters are in trouble and flanagan is
like
oh i'm in trouble i'll call o'brien and
let's get to brian on the phone and
o'brien's like oh don't worry about it
i'll get john c
reilly to come in it's riley o'brien and
flanagan look we gotta we have to watch
each other's backs that's the way it
works yeah
this place has been such a i mean like
the heart of my community
in l.a even though i'd live pretty far
away from here like
it you know ellie you get a lot people
talk about how it's so alienating
everyone's off in their own little
pockets but this place has been a hub so
i want to say on behalf of every all the
fans of largo and all the performers of
largo
thank you oh well coming here and
spending your money here so that the
place
survives i really appreciate it well
we're not paying them
i don't have to it turns out we're
related uh i said no it's been a really
nice thing it's been a thing it's worked
out for everybody so
uh we've been really happy to do it